hey everyone xerath register nurse Orion
common in this video I want to go over
the veins that I love to use whenever
I'm drawing blood or starting IVs so in
order to be successful whenever you're
drawing blood or starting IVs you really
have to know a couple things number one
you need to know the name of the vein
that you're going to use and its
location along with what can that vein
actually handle for instance some veins
can only handle about a 20 or a 22 gauge
IV cannula versus some of them can
handle 18 gages 16 gages so you really
want to know which veins can do that now
what means do I love to use whenever I'm
drawing blood or starting IVs okay
number one which I think the consensus
is probably the same for this is the
median cubital vein this is here in a
moment you're gonna see a large vein
right in the bend of the arm and it's
perfect for drawing blood I also like to
use accessories cephalic vein along with
the median vein of the forearm and of
course those hand mains the dorsal
venous network so we have our tourniquet
on up here on the top of the arm and I
want to show you these veins so first
I'm going to show you the media cubital
vein and it is located right here and as
you can see it's nice and large perfect
for those blood draws and it arises out
of your cephalic vein which is right
here now this is our patient's left arm
so on the right arm it's going to be the
opposite but we have the cephalic vein
right here and then over through here
you can't see it as well as the bacilli
and where the cephalic in the basilic
start to connect as here at this median
cubital vein now this main like I said
great for blood draws you can use it for
IVs the problem with it though is that
it's in the band of this arm so as the
patient is eating moving around getting
up it's going to cause them a lot of
pain and it can infiltrate and mess up
the vein so unless it's like last resort
you can't find any other veins on this
arm or the patient needs like a CT PE
protocol with an 18 gauge in one of
those large veins you can go there use
it and then just take it out and go
somewhere else but I like to keep that
available from blood next is
accessory cephalic vein hence its name
it comes coming off of that cephalic
vein up through here now this is really
one of my favorite veins to start IVs in
number one it doesn't really roll it's
easy to stabilize you're not gonna stick
the needle in there and it rolls to the
side don't you just love and that
happens no not really and it's a
relatively large vein so we can easily
hold an 18 gauge now the thing is
whenever you do use this for IVs because
it starts up in here don't go in this
Bend of this arm go down because it
comes down and you can just stick your
IV right there and the patient can move
their arm bend it they're not going to
have problems so this is really a good
vein another vein I like to use is
located on the forearm so we don't have
a bend of an arm causing the patient and
issues and it is the median vein of the
forum also called the anti brachial vein
and it is this vein right here it comes
out of the palm of the hand now as you
can tell this vein is not as big as the
accessory cephalic and that media
cubital vein so whenever you go to stick
this for like an IV you want to probably
pick like a 20 or 22 gage instead of an
18 gauge I have seen a limited amount of
18 gages in this fame because you know
everyone's Anatomy is different some
people have bigger veins there so you
want to think about that another thing
is that this these veins can run deep on
patients who have a lot of sub-q fat on
their forearms so you might be able to
see the vein but whenever you go to
stick it you don't immediately get that
blood roll because the veins a little
bit deeper so keep that in mind and that
also is true for these veins up here on
the bend of the arm as well and lastly
the veins of the hand the dorsal venous
network and these veins are great for
drawing blood starting IVs but some
things you want to remember okay first
of all these veins like how this patient
has their hand open if you go to stick a
needle in this vein with the hand in
this position this vein is just gonna
roll see how that rolls like that what
you'd want to do is you want to
stabilize it so have them make like this
like this and look that keeps that vein
nice and still why you go with the
needle
to draw blood or advance a cannula now I
have a whole video on how to prevent
rolling veins if you need some more tips
on that another thing to remember is
that these veins sometimes they're
really superficial on people like here
they're nice and engorged and
healthy-looking so they'll be great for
an IV or drawing blood however on some
patients who have a lot of sub-q fat on
the hands they're hard to get to they're
super small or like very fragile and
they blow easy so always look at that
look at the health of the vein before
you try to stick it with a needle now
when choosing a vein when you're
starting an IV there are some things you
want to keep in mind number one you want
to ask yourself okay what's this patient
here for are they just here for like a
short stay because they need a quick
procedure or they're just here for
observation or they're gonna be
hospitalized because they need treatment
maybe they need some blood products or
they're gonna have to get some vest
can't type drugs like potassium think oh
my son just to name a few so you want to
select your site and your sizing your
needle appropriately because for
instance vancomycin is really hard on
the veins and you want to use a large
vein rather than a small vein next ask
the patient where they prefer that you
draw blood or start an IV because
patients tend to be experts on where
they know that you're going to be
successful at getting that IV or drawing
blood in some patients love to have IVs
or blood rolls in their hands while some
prefer that media cubital vein that's
the only place they want blood drawn and
that's the only place they want an IV so
always ask your patient and lastly
sometimes you're just gonna have to draw
blood or start an IV where you can
because if you're working with patients
who have severe cardiac disease or renal
disease they really don't have much to
stick they're very very limited and
where you can even get IV access and
I've seen IVs and creative places like
in the feet and the little fingers on
the arms up in the neck anywhere you can
get them so always keep that in mind and
if that does happen and your patient is
thinking lots of fluids IV drugs things
like that you want to get with the
physician
you want to ask hey is this patient a
candidate for a central line because I
may benefit the patient a little bit
better okay so those are some tips on
choosing veins when starting IVs or
drawing blood thank you so much for
watching and don't forget to subscribe
to our channel for more videos